so we know about the tension between the
number one and two people at the Justice
Department Jeff Sessions and rod
Rosenstein respectively and Trump at one
point was trying to push Jeff Sessions
to leave because sessions is recused on
Russia Trump has also been considering
firing rod Rosenstein who because of
sessions recusal is overseeing the
Russia investigation Trump at one point
was much more aggressively talking about
ousting one or both of them but anyway
this has been going on for a while but
the new story is that we haven't talked
much about the number three at the
Justice Department and that's Rachel
Brand and she's quitting ok this is
interesting for a few different reasons
not the least of which is just the sort
of general staff implosion that has been
happening in the Trump administration
more people leaving more positions being
empty but Rachel Brand leaving is extra
compelling because brand would have been
next in line after rod Rosenstein in the
Justice Department succession Charter
hierarchy to oversee the Russia
investigation so officially Rachel Brand
is leaving because she got a great job
at Walmart she's going to be the global
governance director which is the highest
legal position that Walmart has now I
don't deny for a second that this is I'm
sure a really nice and cushy position
that pays way more than whatever she's
earning is the number three person in
the Justice Department but do we really
believe that this is the reason right in
other words if Rachel Brand were
thrilled with how things were going in
Trump's Justice Department would she
even be open to new jobs so early in
trump's first term knowing that at the
end of one term if she wants to leave
then she'd still be able to get a really
great cushy job like this one this is
clearly a signal that number one
Rachel Brand wants nothing to do with
dealing with Trump in her role at the
Justice Department and number two this
might also signal that it's more likely
than we think that Rosenstein for one
reason or another might not be
overseeing the Russia investigation that
much longer which would have put Rachel
Brand in charge
of that investigation and there's one
other angle on this if Trump does fire
Rosenstein and Rachel Brand is gone and
that position isn't filled which has
been the mo of the Trump administration
to leave these positions open for a long
time that means that power goes to the
fourth person in the Justice Department
hierarchy who is the Solicitor General
who's currently no Francisco that's not
a name we've really heard before if you
start hearing the name null Francisco
it's going to be a name to pay attention
to and meanwhile total disarray at the
Trump administration dozens of people
without permanent security clearances
hundreds of positions unfilled constant
turnover in key departments including
the Justice Department and the FBI and
now Rachel Brand leaving is sort of the
culmination of that we will be following
this closely because the staffing issues
and sort of lack of staffing at the
Trump administration it just keeps
getting to be a bigger and bigger issue
and a lot of people in fact on our
reddit discussion forum are talking
about this check that out at david
pakman.com slash reddit very busy Monday
show next an investigation into Gwyneth
Paltrow's pseudo-science goop website
and much more stay with us today's
episode is sponsored in part by custom
apparel manufacturer Indo Chino I have a
custom-made Indo Chino suit and I had
this problem where I would buy suits and
they just would never fit right even
when I had them tailored like the the
seat was huge and it looked like I had
this gigantic butt which would be fine
if I had it but I don't actually have
that the sleeves were never exactly the
right length or they didn't fit quite
right on the shoulders and I went to
Indo chinos Boston showroom Chris
measured me from head to toe and a
couple weeks later I had a suit that fit
me perfectly with the fabric I liked the
pockets I liked all the customizations
that I liked if you don't live near an
Indo Chino showroom you can shop online
at in go Chino calm and
my listeners and viewers can get any
premium Indo Chino suit for just three
hundred fifty nine dollars at Indo Chino
calm when you enter the code Pakman at
checkout that's over fifty percent off
the regular price for a premium
made-to-measure suit and shipping is
free a lot of my friends have gone into
the boston showroom and gotten great
Indo Chino gifts for people in their
lives and I just love every every time I
just wore my suit actually to a to a
gala over the weekend that's a story for
another day
by the way and a dozen people must have
said that's just an amazingly well
fitting suit where did you get that and
I told them I got it from Chris at endo
Chino so one more time that's Indo Chino
dot-com promo code Pakman to get any
premium suit for 359 plus free shipping